hello and welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv and movie channel except we're
going to be talking movies and whatever
we like to say so not sci-fi just your
moving tv channel and i am joined by our
resident american
stormy hola
how are you doing sir i'm doing well how
are you not too bad i've got a headache
it feels like something is stabbing me
really hard in the back of the head
right there like a knitting needle so if
you see me just every so often just go
oh
that is why
but today anyway i'm going to ignore my
headache
and we're going to talk about
what makes the perfect movie what sort
of
you know what sort of movies do we think
are you know just not just great
but perfection but before we get into
that nonsense what have you been
watching this week stormy
this week
so i watched the first episode of the
orville
good morning
what did you think
um i thought
it was very um
emotive i thought there was you know
some big deal going on there i thought
it was
perfect star trek i absolutely to be
honest adored it so
but i love the order i love that show i
love segment island i love that new
character
um i thought the
i thought it was very well thought
through
um but the second episode is better
something happens in the second episode
oh okay so i really thought that you
know the first episode was
you know like it felt like last season
you know
and um
and i was really shocked that again the
twitter social outrage
the the the the accusations of wokeitude
fox news fox news did a whole 20 minute
segment on it
really i'm just like yeah and it's like
yeah they talked about
some serious issues but it was fallout
from what happened in the last series
yeah so the whole battle the whole thing
with isaac there was it's not like it
was for no reason that they were talking
about suicide
there was a logical path towards what
happened and and it was trying to deal
with everyone's shock and yeah you know
trying to process what had happened
um
you know don't ignore that i thought it
was quite realistic and quite um
quite powerful
yeah i mean you know it's it's
you know and i heard a lot of the story
from the this episode of the orville
i've heard from
um
us veterans from the iraq and
afghanistan wars it's like i've heard
this story before well i've heard those
feelings before from other you know it's
like
i've seen this episode before but it was
kind of in real life but without the
spaceships
[Music]
and
i think it did treat
it did a good one for you know the
issues the really complex issues
surrounding suicide
and um
i mean i i think that's what made it a
great episode
exactly um
the one thing i
love
as well is that the budget has really
been pushed yeah it looks like which i
really am happy about kevin mckay was
wondering if malaysia has ever joined or
um or just brad i don't know
brad's seen my videos because he's had a
go at me but anyway
brad right sorry from stargate um i
really loved them up the um budget
um i think the sets are really upped i
thought the only thing that was a
downside for me that whole thing with
the new fighter
i'm hoping that's going to be important
later because they spent a long time
they did you've seen that little thing
and flying it around and i know that was
also to do with that the woman could do
the five dimensions or whatever you know
right it was supposed to introduce her a
little bit but that went on for a while
and that was the only thing i would say
um
oh yeah i want one but it took a long
time the second episode i won't spoil it
for you but it is classic next
generation sort of um sci-fi it is
absolutely
perfect if you like strange new worlds
you're going to love this basically so
um who needs strange new worlds and
we've got the auroville
yeah well you know that was the other
thing i watched i got caught up on the
strange new worlds
um
the thing that really drives me to just
absolute distraction
is pike's haircut man yep i mean he i
mean that's gone places where no man has
gone before i mean it is it is a tower
of
yeah
he's been working out as well but i
think that's the modern um thing of star
trek isn't it and they've invented a
hair gel in the future that can actually
handle that
um which is phenomenal um he spent a lot
of time working on that hairdo
considering he's supposed to be a
captain and you think he'd be busy he
also works out a lot i've seen the last
episode and he's got some pecs boy
wow yes you know and
during the the the first episode of this
he was riding around you know in the
snow on a horse
and he kind of had this grizzly adams
thing going you know look really good at
it but it did he didn't have the tower
of pisa
you know leaning off to the uh
over his right eye it was
the story was great i mean it was
awesome you know
and but it was like
pike man
i tell you what else i've been watching
them and i'm on the fourth episode of
the boys
which is a tv show i have to watch away
from my wife because um
says see you next tuesday word a lot and
she hates that word
um but um but yeah um i i just love that
show that show appeals to my childish
side quite a lot
and then
that blew up because like
it appeals on that side um and it's one
of those series that every so often you
go yeah i can't believe they're doing
that
and i'm watching it it's like but um i
love that show it's um
it's
it's just ridiculous enough
but also if we really had superpowers
it's also like like
yeah human beings are that scummy that
we would actually do that if some of us
had superpowers so it's like um but i
love that series
but
anything else you want to watch before
we get into this subject
speaking of superpowers i kind of
stopped watching uh the peacemaker i
know it it's getting better but it's
just it i don't think it was never my
kind of show
um i loved that show more than
as well
i don't i hated the movie i hated it
right yeah they absolutely hate um
suicide squad and the suicide squad
whatever awful
um
as soon as he started dancing they had
me
i do love eagerly
i can't remember his character's name so
i watched it when it first came out so
i've watched for a few months but i just
i just love the whole thing from
beginning to end i thought it was
fantastic and i thought it was
ridiculous but you know i'm really not
feeling strange in the world
yeah yeah yeah that you're in a minority
there sir most people are loving it i've
not seen enough of it to have an opinion
yet but i will i promise i will get an
opinion at some point
but i keep seeing bits we haven't got
paramount plus here yeah
22nd of june
i thought i was all excited i thought it
was the 22nd of may and it's not just
22nd of june
the other thing i i absolutely totally
binged
all of it season four stranger things
yes i don't know
it's good to know that was
that was let's call it impactful yeah oh
kate bush went to number one here in the
uk
the number one everywhere i think
yeah i should have been a singer
um but but yeah no i absolutely love
that i can't wait for the next two
seasons the next last two episodes
like four hours of classic
i can't wait it was just you know it was
you know
matthew modine just plays the ultimate
uncaring madman
let's torture some kids
you know and then go on a picnic
and all the kids are dead what did you
do
why did i instigate through my crazy
psychotic psychological 100 manipulation
brainwashing cult that i've got
underground no how could you what did
you do
i didn't do [ __ ] that
no no it wasn't sick
there was a spoiler i was getting ready
to just shoot clean out of my head and
uh you have to say spoilers are headset
those are rules for these things i just
don't i'm not even gonna say it it's
just because it's all kind of predicated
on
stuff that we kind of talked about we
really shouldn't have talked about but
it's just all watch it
it's great so watch it everyone else
watched it though it's the number one
show on netflix by a mile so
a biggest opening weekend of any show
ever on netflix as well which is saying
something for uh streaming services was
number one for so long
um
just discovered a four-hour two-part
mini series when you mentioned the drum
restraint
tell me what it was called bob because i
think i saw that
uh
don't remind me what it's called
right so today's topic anyway anyway a
little chat about thing i was watching
or i've just done a video which isn't
out yes it's spoilers um
about the predator the new predator
movie that's coming out and it just made
me think about how the original arnold
schwarzenegger predator
is
one of the rare beautiful things in
cinema and television that it's actual
perfection
there is nothing about that movie i
would change
um
and that just made me start thinking
about how you know what for one what
makes a perfect movie how do you have to
break it down to what do they have to
get right
for film to reach that pinnacle not just
a great film but
you know the ultimate in its genre and
you know and what other films have come
close or what films have been ruined
because the you know they get one of
these
bits wrong
um
but stormy what do you think before we
crack i've sort of broken this down into
five
things within range which we could talk
about
i started thinking about this and
wow this has got scrape great special
effects this has great sound this has
great music and then i was like
well you know there are a lot of really
great
movies that had none of that
fantasy whatever genre so what was it
you know in the oncology did a paper on
hitchcock you know hitchcock was really
good with the tools of the time
you know but his his um
his real talent was
not overdoing it
he had i mean you know he had access to
everything but he just didn't overdo it
and so
i mean there's lots of things he could
have done with the birds with psycho the
tools that were out there that he just
never used because
he was always trying to push the story
forward yeah i think at the very end of
the day
it's the story that is
is the centerpiece there's a
there's a book i think it's actually
titled story
uh that when if you work for pixar when
you go to work for pixar you have to
read the book i think that even the
receptionist has to read the book title
about storytelling and how you tell a
story properly
and at the very end of the day all the
pixar films
kind of follow that book
yeah
formula to the marvel movies yeah yeah
yeah and um and it goes and also it's
just didn't start with story it goes
back to uh aristotle's poetics
how to still tell a story and
we've kind of been you know
do you think we'd be talking aristotle
when we had this when i thought of this
subject i didn't i didn't think we'd be
going oh well
well you know hollywood's been using
aristotle like a [ __ ] for years you
know but seriously if you've never had
the opportunity
or the time
uh read aristotle's poetics
yeah
can i read the clip notes sure
i'll go right here
i basically thought i broke this down
into four areas that i could think of i
i did two story but i did story and
script i want them together because i
think
there are loads of films that have got
amazing stories but the script lets it
down all the things today i did think
about the special effects definitely
with the world to my sci-fi movies um
uh the edit
which we'll talk about in a minute
because it's
just
getting a good editor on a film
um is think well against that milkman i
do think the timing of a movie when a
movie is released and whether it hits
um
the the genre at the time you know that
the people the community the time
and casting is just vital it doesn't
matter how good a film is but i honestly
think to even be a good film you've
really got to
do pretty well in all of these five
areas yeah maybe special effects you can
get away with
um god's sake hey shelly how are you
sorry we got um
got some i got a block
i got a lot of naked chick adverts on my
when we go live i'm i'm being attacked
by these bots i don't know why they
happen youtube really needs to do
something about that
um anyway
um i think special effects you can get
away with i think there are really good
films that don't necessarily have
amazing special effects yeah um
sometimes they have very crappy special
effects
but
if that bleeds into the film sometimes
if it's just space cowboys with them
uh
i want to say hoffman
hell is his name
that's a terrible movie awful movie um
but it's supposed to be it's a b movie
um it's one point they've got square
pigs because they're shipping square
pigs in space um not space cab with
space truckers
space explorers
so they fit in the back of the thing
properly and stuff like the effects are
terrible
they forget about gravity loads times
but the director actually years later
said we did it on purpose
we didn't want it we wanted this to be a
b movie we could have done a much better
special effects but we didn't want to we
wanted to look a bit crappy you know
so
you know but i think sometimes special
effects can be there but sometimes
effects can make a movie i still think
avatar is
i is it is close to i don't think it's
perfect i think it's too slow but i
think it's close to a perfect movie and
the special effects are
friends and center
you know that's one of the big reasons
why it's such a great film i don't think
the story is particularly
clever i think it's because it's so
visually spectacular that's why it's a
great movie
um
it's a few if we talk about casting
though there's a few films that have
come close to perfection that have been
ruined
by bad casting
amber
oh god i know she's going to she heard
that instead of sucking it they've
doubled her minutes i really am bloody
aquaman too
that girl is never going to be even a
good film never mind a great film
[Music]
suddenly i'm no longer enthused to see
aquaman too
anyway but i mean other than jason momoa
who is brilliant it's the first one was
not a good film it was just that jason
my mother was great
um
for me anyway did you ever see moa's uh
i mean you maybe haven't uh he did the
sci-fi thing for apple plus called c-s-e
oh my yeah that was
he's done two seasons he's doing a third
i believe yeah yeah yeah and it was a
producer for that show as well yeah it's
amazing it was an amazing show it was a
it was just
uh
anyway
that was um yeah i did and it's that's
one of those great sci-fi it was just
open you know end of the world type of
shows that
everybody's just everyone's gone blind
they said the world so it's gone
completely collapsed and uh it's
fantastic fantastic series
i'm sure there's a third series coming
but i might be making that up i do make
things up sometimes unintentionally but
you know
um
blade runner um i
i would agree with you there actually
the blade runner is close to a perfect
movie again
just because of the story
the casting was perfection
um you know rude kahawa
in that in a movie is just incredible
um
you know and then
you know the the music and everything in
that movie was just
spot on um if you think about the
right let's talk about the edit
editing right
one of the things that's really
important for a movie to be decent is to
get the um rhythm right
you've got to get the timing right you
know you're going to um you're going to
build up the rhythm and you have the you
know the director is really important on
that but the editor is really important
as well because you know cutting scenes
together quickly and you you build up
the momentum towards something happen
then you slow it down when you're in the
emotional things and you know you get
that rhythm of the movie right i'll keep
going back to predator because i
actually watched it last night and one
of the things about predator
um which is why again is so perfect is
because the editing is perfect it's like
rhythm of the film is just and it draws
you in and then obviously you know i
took my special effects and how they
were just subtle enough
that they still stand up today that you
can still watch a movie now and it
doesn't you know it doesn't nothing
stands out nothing goes oh that's
pre-cgi it's all just stunning
then i watch a michael bay movie
and and i and i want to injure myself i
just you know the transformers films
if ever you watch transformers movies
play
how how many times since it's a good
drinking game how many times will other
people in this film 100 have died if
that had happened in real life you'll be
hammered by the end of the film it's a
lot you like every so often it's like
somebody goes flying through them and
then take another drink
the the thing i never did like about
transformers is
they put so much
visually on the screen like how they're
changing and then when they're fighting
they're also
i never could really visually discern
what was going on yeah but that's the
problem isn't it but also the edit is so
bad
yeah the edit is like
did it long pause
long pause it's just like for god's sake
or you just pick
whether you want an action sequence or a
slow emotional sequence or something
else and just do one for now but michael
bay does it in all his films yeah it's
very much his style and it does my head
in the also the other thing that
transforms is that the voices of the
transformers seems to be very
disconnected to actually what's going on
on screen
yeah so the writing was pretty bad as
well um
but the edit for a film there have been
loads of films over the years i think
that it would that the director when you
see the director's cut afterwards that
is partly because the director's not
gonna have to basically re-cut the movie
because the editor has [ __ ] it
yeah part of my french um it's so
important um
how about so so
cast in though
i think about films like
big budget movies right so big budget
movies lots and lots of money spent on
them that have been completely ruined
by bad casting
robin hood prince of thieves
robin hoods with an american twang i'm a
nottingham man yeah
you know is it awful
the prince of persia film with jake
gyllenhaal
that is he's not an action hero it was
awful
um john carter
john carter isn't a bad film
taylor kitsch is is not is a good actor
but he's not he shouldn't have been in
that role at all it's it was just i mean
i as soon as i saw that advert for that
i'm like post-effect i'm like that ain't
going to work
um
but casting is
a bit of an art form you know i mean
it's
um
like i didn't i mean i loved daniel
craig but him in like uh cowboys versus
aliens yeah it was just
i don't know it just didn't quite work
i couldn't i can't actually put in words
well i mean it was a fun movie but i
just
you know
kind of the opposite of that you know
timothy olyphant
as the sheriff in mandalorian
was spot
absolutely spot on you
um i like that
um obviously the the creator of
mandalorian had seen justified the
of the five six years and just went
we just wanted him
yeah
what's my motivation for this just just
do what you did in justified that'll do
i started to watch justified again today
so today it's such first episode is so
good i i've always liked timothy
elephant when i saw him in die hard 4.0
talking about perfect movies die hard
what's up there first die hard movie
did you ever see him in uh deadwood
no i never saw one i never watched it
it's an hbo property and
it's like taking swearing
cursing to a shakespearean level
watch three or four episodes in the
just the i mean
the art form of cussing
wow
i thought i was going to casting nope
dead wood
um the main guy in that whose name is
going to escape me uh he was loved join
the tv series over the british actor he
was fantastic and then yeah i saw a
couple of episodes so i was in a period
where i didn't have sky tv
and batman forever all of the batman
film films after the first one until the
modern ones were all awful
because mainly because of um the
director
but um
so
what are the films if you think
oh you're thinking about your machine
right
ian mcshane thank you yeah yeah yeah
he's great yeah you did the tv series
over at ian's
was one second behind you um yeah he did
see if he could love joyce so he was
always just this this cheeky chappy
character in the uk and then he went to
do deadwood and she's like jesus didn't
know he could do that
it was a completely different sort of
role for him but it was um it just
worked and it was fantastic and he had
that midwestern accent down perfect yeah
yeah so you seen he was a londoner he
had a bloody uh yeah a cheeky chappy uh
east end accent when he was over here
something
but he's a proper actor though he is he
was you know like properly trained actor
and he's seen some of the stuff he's
done since deadwood as well he's just he
can do anything he can actually do
anything
um so yeah how about
so that's the edit for me anyway
um i do think sometimes a film can come
out and it's got to hit the right
sort of cultural notes you know when
something's going on um i think i do
think it's important that the film
sometimes doesn't
doesn't get watched because it just
doesn't fit
somehow there's you know there's just
something but i think what i'm trying to
say is i think there's an x factor with
these things there's this that thing
that you just can't quite
put your finger on sometimes when a
movie goes from being
um just
say die hard
that's a film that's been remade a
million times since but the story is
actually not that
um clever
um
nobody thought bruce willis could be an
action hero
um
the music's okay but it's not great it
was made with no money
and nobody in fox wanted to make it and
they all thought it was just you said
they had to make it so
they had nothing but problems making
that film um in the end they basically
got me it basically got made because
they just sort of went it's almost like
they just
got bored of listening to people moan so
they said oh okay well
um
and they were only like sort of film at
night when no one else was around and
this sort of thing it nearly didn't get
made you know and it's like um
there's a similar story like home alone
which i think is pretty close to the
original you know it's a it's a perfect
movie for what it is
um
same thing nearly didn't get made
um
you know because nobody wants to make it
so you know even these people that
professionals in this is what i'm trying
to say even these people that you know
like making movies is their life
sometimes don't know what a good film is
they can't they you know they wouldn't
know if a good filmmaker slapped him in
the face sort of thing
um
theory about um
why um
star wars episodes four five and six
were so much better than one two and
three
well
because
you know in episodes four five and six
people still had the courage to tell
george lucas to his face no
yeah especially the editor
but by the time
he comes back around to where he can
make first and second and the third
who in hollywood was ever going to tell
george lucas no
yeah
i mean yes mr lucas yes lucas jar jar
bink's best idea ever mr lucas he's not
at all irritating
i'm not you're taking me sir he's
amazing
bye-bye yeah judge i will go public
bye bye judger um i have a similar
theory with tim burton
um i think the first batman with michael
keaton is a piece of art i think it is
it is actually pretty close to a perfect
movie but it also then became the
biggest um hit at the time it was your
number one on the how much money it made
yeah it was you know it made a
phenomenal amount of money when when
some superhero movies weren't making
money
and then tim burton was just allowed to
go they just went well tim burton you're
obviously a genius you must do whatever
you want in the next movie and um and
then in the next movie well i think joel
schumacher sort of took over the third
in the i think and but then he's been
doing whatever he wants ever since and
it's just like
god how many good films has tim burton
ruined
because he's got that style and whatever
you know it's fair enough but i mean
it's just i
i love um the idea of a nightmare after
christmas like before christmas yeah the
idea is great i think it looked great i
think it was a and that film is but in
places it's boring
because of tim burton and his style and
the way he has to make movies and
it's just it just makes me want to hurt
myself
um not as bad as watching the johnny
chap challenge chocolate factory movie
makes me want to hurt myself though that
film makes me want to actually
get your finger off
yeah i'll i'll cut i'll cut whatever you
want off rather than watch that film
you know but you know burton has a
tremendous
fan following i mean he could make
anything and he'd still do great because
he has a tremendous fan following for
that kind of aesthetic in a film
it really is amazing
and it's to just stand out from anything
else i mean i i i have to argue it's
just not for me i think that's the
problem i i can respect
the the style and i can respect what he
does it's just not for me um
but i just wish sometimes he had
somebody to tone him back
um like he think i can think he did for
the first batman
right just to pull him in a little bit
and i think he would make a better movie
if if
to do whatever he wants but
but saying that shouldn't a director do
have free role isn't that why he's there
i mean it's definitely the director's
piece of art
you know but it's also the studio and
the producer's money
in the studio pay a lot of other people
to have their input that they trust so
it's not
um
[Music]
things don't go awry but there are a few
filmmakers in hollywood that this just
whatever they go whatever they say goes
either whatever the director says goes
you know
um
i mean how you know so like a new hope
star wars new hope episode four
you know the studio got their cut and
then how many cuts did george lucas
produce
yeah you know over and over and over
and the time he got the episode for one
no one i mean they knew it was
regardless of how good or bad the movie
was going to be how questionable jar jar
binks would have been right now things
are going to make a ton of cash yeah
where was steven spielberg who was going
to run roughshod over spielberg
probably the one of the best cinema
makers
in the last hundred years i mean he has
got this
i mean he has got a gift you know far
beyond anybody else that's in the
business today or since i've been alive
he is just good we go i i think every
generation you have movie makers
from a certain generation i think
i do wonder this is just me to think
i've talked ahead who is the big
sort of
spielberg
um
oh forgot his name who did the aliens
movies
uh it's got this guy on my head
um
well just look but then you know you oh
the aliens would have just that's just
been a sundry amount of people
yeah
james cameron
[Music]
and then dave somebody what was his last
name did the third with extreme um what
was his name dave he also did um
he had a tv show on uh
about washington dc david
[Music]
i'm trying to remember who did the um
the covenant movie as well who produced
that or directed it who's the director
oh that was written
bigly scott yeah yeah he did the first
one he's been doing all the other ones
yeah he directed him to me um so i mean
i i think he's he's a great movie maker
um you know obviously you've got think
people like um david fincher david
fincher did number three
who's the big sort of movie
makers now though because i don't see
spielberg doesn't make movies like he
used to um ridley scott doesn't make
movies like he used to he's still got
he's still powerful you know still does
great work but
i think every generation sometimes has
like the the you know like in sport
every generation has that like the roger
federer you know or
the the jordan or the michael jordan or
the things like this um
i would say james gunn would be
one of the generators
yeah
he just makes some great movies love god
i mean you know peacemaker right um also
guardians of the galaxy yeah you know
you say kevin fey is sort of he's the
he's the like probably the most powerful
man in cinema right now i mean he did
such a good job with the marvel that
basically disney handed him the company
and and not quite you know to me right
and now he he can do the wrong but he's
not really a movie maker he's a manager
you know he's not a director he's not a
writer he's not i think he's he's a
manager he's really great at
he's there well they've got a formula
and we're sticking to this formula and
then he gets the right people in to do
it's like he's like a great football
manager um
i'm not sure who the the
who the big players are now that you
think
they can do no wrong well we never know
boom what is it
we really never know the big players
until a decades past
we re i mean you know when gremlins came
out well this little steven spielberg
guy if he really works hard at it he may
make something of himself
and uh and it was that way daily snacks
want to lose what an idiot
i mean you know when lucas came out with
thx is like what the hell is that
you know and then you know then there
was like no one i mean then he did
american graffiti and that did very well
and then he got to star wars and what is
this [ __ ] oh god let's yeah
just let's try to kill this in the
bathtub if we can
never exactly happen and then you know
we never know
these are the emerging artists until
decades pass and they've shaped culture
in ways we've never really expected
so you know it's like
john favreau you know so far yeah i am
um chris nolan has just been suggested
um yeah i mean you could say definitely
a decade ago he was the man he could do
no wrong
um like you know david fincher you know
he did the disaster of aliens three with
extreme
uh studio
meddling
yeah and then his next i think his next
film was the game
which was
yeah awesome awesome film awesome movie
yeah
i think that is the truth okay this one
that there's
there's always
somebody in there that's sort of like a
great producer great actor we do i think
it's maybe just a bit different at the
moment
in that
that the people that we know about or
maybe not the the producers but i mean
there's like
one thing i just liked by steven
spielberg was he used to make films like
hook
to pay for films like schindler's list
yeah and he was always doing that sort
of those sort of deals with studios i
will make this movie for you that's a
steaming pile of crap
i don't want to make but i want to make
uh the thingy to tibet whatever it's
called it's like you know so you fund
that and i'll make you a crapload of
money if you do this and the witch won't
but you might win an oscar
um you know i'm just like
that was one of the things that
spielberg goes to love and i don't see a
great deal of that now it seems to be
just like
how do we make money but then
i say that james gunn does make still
makes very low budget very thing movies
that you know he
stuff he wants to see
rather than just um
um just the you know guardians of the
galaxy three or whatever he's still the
stuff he wants to do and then anyway i
don't i don't believe for a second
peacemaker would have been made
ten years ago if it wasn't for
now he
basically got that makes tv show made
through
blood sweat and tears and because he
basically insisted he goes i know we're
making this damn tv series it'll be
awesome that i can actually almost see
the you know the people who actually
write tracks going oh this is gonna be
bad um it's connected to a really crap
movie that's done really badly and um
and we're gonna bloody now make a tv
series yeah i mean for the the producers
for the uh
for that show i mean you can kind of
call them the suicide squad because
nobody believed in having the peacemaker
as a project it's like what
if this failed and you're and and you
want to put more money yes i do
and you're stuck in a contract it's like
okay fine the producers would come to
suicide squad yeah
and you want to base it around john
cena's character didn't he die he's just
like don't worry about it
oh is it
dead is this like you know
it'll still work and so that tv it was a
much better tv show than it ever was a
movie um which just happened sometimes
it's very rare but sometimes you know
that happens
um
i i'll get in the comments by the way
guys anyone that's watching at the
moment what perfect movies do you can
you think of the things the films that
you think you cannot think of anything
wrong with it ian did come up with
predator but i think he was a little bit
late
i made a list
go hit me hit me with your list
this is not
this one is not sci-fi
it's not fantasy
just movies tonight just moving okay so
fast times at ridgemont high never seen
it don't know what you're talking about
it nailed
it nailed the culture of me growing up
in high school
it was just
perfect
the the the the um the writing the
directing the the the stunts even the
culture issues of the day was just it
was just perfect and i've always i mean
i could just go you know turn this off
go watch it and have a good afternoon it
was just really really good
fast times at ridgemont high
you know there's a film like that when i
was a kid was um i don't know if it's a
perfect movie but it was one of those
movies
a rare thing that i could watch any time
forever there's a film called a no but i
don't know anyone has ever watched it as
a class act with um
gene hackman
and it was a strange it was it was wrote
loosely based on a true story i believe
but it was a courtroom drama and um
there was a car that there was a fault
and it blew up and the people at the car
company realized it was cheaper to leave
the car as it was
and a few people die and get sued than
it was to fix the problem
that was the core of the movie basically
but it was when i fell in love with gene
hackman and then after that i watched
bat 21 which is just a normal movie but
um
good morning vietnam
perfect example
um
the music and good morning vietnam but
yeah that class act was just oh
my
god yeah yeah yeah yeah gene hackman
mural is his master antonio yeah yeah i
was i could watch that any time i was
watching about 50 times when i was a kid
i don't know why i do like those
procedural kind type of things i like i
think i really want them to bring like
law and order
um
back
um as like the police drama but i want
them to have like a couple of episodes
on the police bit then a couple of
episodes on the on the courtroom bit i
wanted to stretch them out of it because
they just did the quote you know it was
half this episode you know 20 minutes on
the police then 20 minutes on the
courtroom i'm like oh okay
um i like those sorts of things but um
yeah shawshank redemption for me i think
is
is one of those movies
written based on a short story it's not
even based on a proper story
um
i i remember having an argument with
somebody once said he was written by st
you know because it was stephen king's
story no it wasn't
yes it was they've had a very long
argument with them
um
it's just one of those films that you
just
you can very easily lose two hours
yeah
and not even and not even care you know
it's just like
and another pick of mine is you know as
we've discussed before on this channel
and others is like um i had a stab at uh
right the uh the iconic swimming pools
forever thank you
thank god for pause anyway
as we've talked on this channel before
you had a
short flirtation with uh making movies
special props and production and so
forth in and around
the film industry of wilmington north
carolina
and you know i went into after that i
went into advertising kind of i did some
uh
other uh indie films just
i got bored
just to kind of do it you know
but the the the i remember the night
i decided to abs that was that dream is
dead as a door kneel i will never make
another
movie maybe a documentary maybe
something like that but not
a movie and that was after the first
like seven eight minutes of the
fellowship of the ring
all right well first seven eight minutes
of the fellowship of the ring telling
the story of the silver alien and
unfinished tales and all that stuff in
that short period of time
leading up to felt to the fellowship
was so
for me mind bogglingly perfect
everything was just
perfect
you know it's like i'm never thinking i
i i i i can never
get close
i it's just i can't you know there's no
way i could even make orcs not look that
good you know i mean it's just and i had
you know experience with making orcs not
you know as a prop and it was just
this is so good i've gotta i've i've
gotta find another thing and i went in
advertising it's full time never looked
back the morgan range was real hobbit
there's lots of production issues with
the hobbit i think that was also forced
by the studio not necessarily peter
jackson because apparently he does have
his [ __ ] all together and in one sock
it's just more studio issues yeah what
are the rings and everyone got every
every sequel to that got
unimaginably better just it was
incredible
that's how to lose about 18 hours your
life for not care yeah yeah yeah
100
and and that was again when you hit this
this thing about like the x factor of
casting they got the casting you know
actors we've never heard of perfect
and this special effects
were mind-bogglingly complicated um in
fact you know the story obviously was
amazing the edit was amazing and i think
it just hit it was released at a time
that was just ideal as well it was when
you know like the effects were just good
enough and the story the ability to tell
that story was good enough
i'm not sure i think it would get
struggles get made then because i think
a streaming service would try to do it
and i think um i think it would struggle
to get made
somebody like you maybe amazon would
make it and it would just be awful and
it would be woke and nonsense so let's
hope they don't do that
so i i i will say that amazon studios
did take
[Music]
a lot of members of tolkien scholars
honest to god tolkien scholars from
cambridge and oxford mixed them in with
a bunch of uh fanboys like
the head of the guy that runs uh the one
ring.net long term really well respected
i don't want i really shouldn't call
them fanboys they were just
dedicated
to his work
and they all said
that's amazing
don't worry it's amazing
and
again we're coming out with people who
really don't have that much studio clout
names you know creators we've never
really heard of maybe some video game
stuff
but if both token scholars
and tolkien
consumers
can agree that this was
just
totally
blew them away
i think we're going to be okay
i do wonder there's a lot of people who
have not seen it that are very angry
about it i'm like let's wait till we see
it oh my gosh making it yet will you
please calm down
i saw people pissed off at about kenobi
before it even before the trailer come
out yeah
you know and
i it's you know the these
these uninformed opinions you know i
just you know i just kind of block these
people i mean because if you've seen it
that's one thing if you don't know what
you're talking about please shut up
about it because you're not adding to
the conversation you're just how the
internet works
that's not how the internet works if you
haven't got an opinion or you haven't
got any information you you still have
to loudly demand that you know what's
best yeah of course
on my channel constantly
whether i like it or not
so i got another one from my list excuse
me i think you'd agree with this one
star trek for the voyage home
that is i i tell you what
do you know when we said about how a
film has to have a good story yeah
to be a perfect movie
the story in star trek voyage home is um
rubbish
it's um it makes no sense uh it's it's
it's almost stupid
but
that film is probably the best of the
original trek movies yes it is um uh i
love wrath of khan wrath of khan is what
saved star trek i think if wrath of card
hadn't been made we wouldn't know it'd
be star trek oh that 60s thing that had
that movie it wasn't very good and wrath
of khan came out um but
for me my favorite is always
undiscovered country but that's only
because it's the first time i ever saw
the cinema
and i love the starting sequence
explosive
um and you know like sue luke who bought
the excelsior fire apartment but um you
know it's like it's that's my favorite
but
well
perfect for is probably the greatest of
the all the star trek films for
undiscovered country that was kind of
the first instance we saw the
you know
the federation kind of having a bad side
you know
you know in in kirk frankly
let them die well that's kind of bad
that's good
genocidal let's put you shoot first ask
questions later um but then they all
resolved the sales and um you know it's
not
i've actually done a video about the new
star trek film again it's in the editing
process and i talk about this these
films quite a lot in that video so most
spoilers but
i do talk about the the connection
between
a film we've just discussed and the next
star trek movie is i've been told that
we're they're going to be elements of
the next star trek movie that we with
the j.j abrams one that we've seen
before
and that we might be quite happy if you
like the undiscovered country you might
be quite happy
so um is this where uh uhura finally
realizes that she really does know
klingon
she she might do
i don't know um i'm just hoping that um
they don't just completely to change the
physics of how a starship works again
because they've done it three times
already let's just see if they do it
again
um
i'm a geek i i think about how the
engine is and if you completely redesign
the engine every film we will notice
and camera
we have notes
it completely changed the design of the
ship every time they took all that it's
got flaps this time no they've took the
flaps away again
but anyway um
yeah i love i love i love that film it's
the voyage home is one of those films
that should not work
but it just does it does then i thought
they did the final frontier and they
went we've got another story that
shouldn't work
and it didn't it
didn't
know we found the ditch
yeah
you know the the funny thing about star
trek five the star trek we don't talk
about uh it's the first rule of being a
trekkie we don't talk about star trek
five the final frontier is that actually
if you break that film up into bits it's
actually really good it's quite funny in
places um there's some really good
scenes in it and the whole thing that i
find in god actually is quite it's quite
good and it's quite funny because you
don't ask god for his id and things like
that i just want to say that deforest
kelly i've always argued was the best
actor
of the original series i mean he i mean
it was that was you know
he just he was the best actor in the
whole series sorry oh he was offended i
don't care
but like there's a
gym i'm a doctor
there's a line where uh they're
celebrating um this is i think a voyage
home also
um they're in or yeah i can't anyway
uh they're in uh kirk's uh apartment you
know and the force kelly's a character
is talking to him you know why are we
treating this birthday
like a uh like a a a funeral you know
and you know deforest kelly he he's and
this is a you've got to be a real film
nerd or or an actor to really appreciate
this nuance
but he's delivering this line and he
said god damn it jim why are we treating
this funeral is this a birthday like a
funeral and he's kind of walking along
the across the room he's got his drink
in his hand and he looks like he's
actually going to a funeral he's going
to a funeral
that it shouldn't have been and he's
angry
and i was just like holy [ __ ] i mean it
was just a really good scene and it was
a good scene because of deforest kelly
not william
williams
casting right for the new series they
did really well actually though the the
j.j abrams movies i thought they did the
casting really well other than chris
pine who was chris brown as an actor i
love
i don't think he's a great kirk but i do
love him as an actor but carl urban as
bones i actually thought was really good
even though it's completely different to
device kelly in almost every way
um he's just he's fantastic in it and
he's just got that
rho hirum thing going yeah
but again it's that x factor it's about
that that thing about getting the
casting right and getting these things
so like i said star trek five bits
perfect together terrible um it's it's a
word it's a film that's less than the
sum of its parts
but then you get some of these other
films that we're talking about and
they're more than the sum of their parts
and it's like how do you explain that
voyage home
is not very good special effects the
story makes no sense it's it's okay well
written bits of it as just stupid even
the bits of it are genius but for some
reason
it worked
it worked it's greater than the sum of
its parts
um and that happens a lot of movers i
would argue somebody mentioned earlier
about the matrix being um
uh maybe we'll get a live action books
bunny movie whoa
here we are aren't we and they're doing
space jam too
isn't that good i'm sure there's been
man i will never watch it but i'm sure
it's been made
um matrix was a really good film you
know it was
uh i first saw it advertised and i said
what in the hell is this you know i
almost didn't go see it i said okay i'm
bored i'll go see it and it was nothing
the the film was nothing like it was
advertised it was advertised as a whole
different kind of thing and then you go
see it
wow
i think i'll go i saw it twice the
afternoon it came out yeah yeah exactly
i i saw it twice i went um i walked out
the cinema with my girlfriend she went
home and i went back to watch it again
100 greater than some of its parts um
it's obviously it's the only reason we
know who keno reeves is other than that
dude that went bill and ted other than
that guy um oh but he i don't know maybe
he didn't go well in the uk but speed
speed did very well here actually yeah
yeah yeah yeah
speed 2 is a classic
um what's a marvelous movie that was it
wasn't it was terrible not the one on
the blue it was on the boat and sandra
bullock says it's our 101
yeah yeah she said she was a contractor
to do it she had no choice but do it
she made a house that's cool she got a
house payment
yeah she did get it she wouldn't get a
husband and it didn't harm a career in
the long run but oh god that was a
terrible movie
so i have
my uh one to my fourth one of course
everyone's gonna agree with this one
star trek for a new hope perfect
well
i mean great
great story
no budget the studio hates it
hates the director wants to get rid of
it
you know and you know
it was going to problem
bother going to the premiere
yeah yeah
let's not advertise it you know let's
try to kill this one in the bathtub too
how many billions later
yeah
oh it became iconic
iconic
i don't know why
i
i find the origin i find new hope
this is going to make me so popular as
a leader of a sci-fi channel i find it a
little boring
i think um it's um it's too slow
for me
but
the problem is the bits of it that are
iconic
anything with solo in in that movie was
brilliant those bits with um with with
solo in a great chewy i love them
all the bits of it are great for me it's
just as a film it's a bit too long i
preferred
return of the jedi and the empire
strikes back
because i thought they were a bit
quicker they're a bit pacier for me
when it first came out
and there's no way i can i can explain
this to somebody that that wasn't there
when star wars first came out
everyone was just stun even if they
weren't a sci-fi fan it was just like
holy [ __ ] nothing had been done like
that before no one had seen anything
like that
and i know i'll freely admit you know uh
return of the jedi much better
um
the uh
episode six was probably the best of
that of of that uh three part series
but it was
man i mean it just shook up culture
i mean it was
people that would never go see a sci-fi
movie went to go see this and they were
stunned
and i think it changed there's so
there's some films that you can almost
say change the world
yeah and i think star wars did it
definitely changed cinema
forever afterwards um and the way cinema
is producing way movies are produced the
way you know it completely
you know i mean
marketing and selling toys and all these
sorts of things that completely changed
everything the way movie makers are i
just love that he
um that they thought it was going to be
such a bomb
that steven spielberg and um
[Music]
uh his name's going on my head george
lucas
and went on holiday instead right george
didn't go to the premiere he went on
holiday instead and on that holiday in
barbados i think was where
steven spielberg thought up indiana
jones yeah so if if he'd have been more
confident about
star wars being a hit he would have gone
to the premiere and we might never have
seen indiana jones which i never had
billions of dollars of box office and i
would argue indiana jones and the last
crusade is pretty much a perfect movie
we've got stronger corner in there
yes
yes actually my dad is scottish for some
reason
and i think that is a brilliant place to
end our little video
i got one more i got one more one more
than i'm going you always drag this out
an hour stormy
god damn it
you
if you've seen this movie if you've even
heard of this movie i will be totally
surprised
it is
it is a george lucas film
yeah called
huh
i've seen it's not it's it it's it's not
you know hardcore sci-fi it's not
fantasy is called the radio land murders
it's a story
about radio land murders it's a story
about
this uh radio station and their
producers and actors making
uh literal
you know radio shows
and the murder
i'm telling you
and
it is it is like and it shows lucas
loves the right things a million miles
an hour i mean when he was just really
left to his own devices
you know the the pacing of the story is
ridiculous and the the pacing that the
radio land murders the the the script
goes
i mean it it it is like the trench scene
in star wars it is
such a good and it's it's just
it's a murder mystery you know who's the
evil guy pulling all the strings you
know it's
radio land
1930 style it's very much the the style
of the genre at the time yeah um i love
ned beatty i've just yeah just because i
knew the film but i couldn't think what
it was christopher lloyd was in it she
was amazing
the guy the main guy though brian benben
was an actor that i always really really
liked and he did a tv series afterwards
which uh called dream on
um which i thought was brilliant at the
time and then he never really
became like an alien you know he never
really pushed on from that he never
really did
but uh yeah george burns was in it
which is just
ah
no no it was a great movie it's a great
movie oh look at this looking at george
burns who was one of the parts to kill
me
well what the radio cinema the actors of
that day was you know i think that was
really a casting but it was just perfect
in every way and
yeah
it's one of those films that i think was
um as you know we're talking about
greater than some of his parts 100 that
it's just
it's just i do wonder sometimes and this
we will be ending on this goddammit
stormy if you sure fine whatever
um
i do think sometimes when
i think a lot of films are ruined by
committee
yes sydney are the masters of this i
think sometimes i think we're talking
about john carter it was ruined by
committees
i think sometimes when a film
they have when the when the executives
don't think it's going to be any good
when they're not that bothered and the
filmmaker is allowed just to just to
make a movie
and go you know and like right this is
how much money i've got right i can do
this i can squeeze a couple more million
maybe
um and and they make something that's
you know really comes from the heart
and the executives and people don't they
leave them alone pretty much to just do
it
that's when we see
perfect movies like die hard which was
completely a movie from love that the
director and the producer was convinced
it was going to be a great movie
the executives of fox weren't and they
pretty much left them alone and several
snake dies at the end it was wonderful
yeah i know
like that he dies i couldn't lean any
further back i'm gonna hit the green
screen
i love a little a little thing i know
about die hard was that um they had to
lie to him about that um and he says the
fear in his eyes is everyone knows how a
great actor he was but um the fear in
his eyes he says was 100 genuine because
they did not tell him how far he would
fall and when they let him go and you
see him falling and it's because at some
point you can actually see his eyes go
oh god
it was really high and they did so they
lied to him they pretended that it
wasn't going to be too bad but they have
to the producer or the i think it was
the director had to have to fight for
him to be in the role because nobody
wanted him exactly the executive
producers were just like who was he
yeah he'd never done anything before
then because you're gonna you're gonna
put him as the main bad guy in this room
and those things because he can do it
um and
then obviously he went on to become one
of the greatest actors of our generation
sorely missed
but uh
also
he was great in bottle shock
yes autoshock is a little napa valley
story about the napa valley wineries uh
is also starring chris pine who i met
had no idea was going to be captain kirk
because i'm an idiot
but yeah he's also in bottle shock he
was also in a great movie called january
man with uh
chris klein
which is a murder mystery movie he's got
a he only plays sort of a background
character in that and he is phenomenal
in it he completely stole the show yeah
quickly stole the movie and that was
before that and then he couldn't get
another role after that for years until
he got diehard
he was he went back to the west end or
whatever yeah i think not getting
another movie and he absolutely stole at
me but nobody ever watched it so
oh well
um
i think we broke that down i think we
figured out that actually we don't know
what makes a perfect movie yeah
neither does anybody else it i i think
that's that's the takeaway is that
executives have no freaking clue and
exactly is when they get out of the way
is when we get a better movie
we get surprises when they get out of
the way
yeah
and um
hey
we just that's the way we live it on it
is when you
there's there is no better feeling that
when you're up late at night on a on a
you know a friday night or something
you're watching one of the hundred and
something channels and you come across a
movie
that you've never heard of um
sure from nottingham he's in that again
man um and you just go
that was bloody brilliant
what a great movie i've never heard of
that film and i loved every second of it
there's um
it doesn't happen very often that's the
problem it doesn't happen very often it
doesn't have very real and the problem
we're having now is but when i back in
there in the days of cable when that was
the only thing you had
was it'd be like you know 200 channels
and you didn't want there
nothing real literally on it was like
50 channels of espn or some sort of
other sports holy crap there was all the
preacher channels
there was abc cbs and nbc at least here
in the states that was producing you
know mediocre quality stuff that just to
sell ad space on
yeah then you'd had the sci-fi channel
that's that for some reason became the
the uh wrestling channel and i don't
know why i haven't been terrible since
and then somebody said hey let's put all
the good [ __ ] on streaming let's get
away from these cable providers and now
we've still got
200 streaming services but now there's
too much to watch and it's infuriating
we're swamped under rubbish and we and
the thing is they're so desperate to
make movies
they just make something to trash and
it's just like but i i love a trashy
movie i was just thinking about um one
of the rare occasions where i've sat
down and watched a film that i had no
expectations of and absolutely loved and
it was a film with ben affleck in um
called phantoms
and i had zero
knowledge of it before i sat and watched
it zero expectation i mean peter o'toole
is useless and leave shreeb it was
actually really really good
um and like say no expectations of movie
at all and it's it's not a good film
don't get me wrong
but um at the time i was just like i
love this film what a great film i loved
it again it was one of those films made
with no it's like a horror sci-fi type
thing but it was um
we watched it completely bombed
i um it was a reason that's watched it
was in it yes rosemary going wasn't it
yes of course i've forgotten about that
yeah it's a while since i've watched it
another film that i think was um
for me
which is a perfect movie my wife is
going to kill me by the way and i
promise i'd be off by seven um but
another film that's for me was perfect
it's a british movie called dog soldiers
which i again went into with absolutely
no expectation and it's a werewolf movie
but for me it's the perfect werewolf
movie
um they may not for me the miz all have
stopped making them after after
dog soldiers at one point you do see a
um a soldier punch um one of the
werewolves in the face and you can see
the rubber nose go going
it's really bad well you know
i i remember that feeling had a liam
cunningham minute which i played was
sir davos i think it was and uh yes
big ginger scottish fella
yeah yeah um
uh per tweeze in it john perry's son
yeah forgot his name but he's great in
it
um it's just one of those films that is
if you haven't seen it 100 go and watch
it um and it's it's the perfect bee
movie it's a perfect look like say stop
making werewolf films just stop it
because the
dog soldiers it's great film twisty as
well
right
i'm going to go and get some very
serious painkillers oh my god my head i
hope you feel better i hope you feel
better i get these i get a bad neck i i
really hurt my neck a few years ago
and i'm doing things i shouldn't have
been doing here's guys a little bit of
personal information for any of the you
know the hardcore fans who are still
with us um you know if you want to know
more about me
i'm going to tell you anyway so um yeah
i really hope my neck a few years ago i
get a broke it and i get a pinched nerve
so if i don't sleep quite right
then the nerve gets pinched and it feels
like there's a knit needle
like i said little back of my head and
then needle in my ear like really going
in there
and painkillers don't do anything so i
just have to ignore it
and i can if i put heat on it sometimes
it'll relieve it and make me not want to
die but other than that
um
[Music]
rendezvous and a popcorn yes random
movies late at night popcorn beer
don't like cats but um
dog at feet that'll do
um but yeah uh so anyway okay i'm gonna
go and lie down
okay you go lie down i'm not i've got to
go make tea yeah me too guys thank you
so much for everybody that's um come in
and had a chat with us this evening it's
been brilliant as always stormy
may as always thank you so much it's
brilliant to have our resident american
uh very welcome next week i'm planning
to do
a bit of a stargate video uh on our live
sunday stream that i'm gonna be doing um
sci-fi sunday which i'm not gonna be
calling it
um i don't know if storm you're gonna be
free but i i know matt our friend that
does our discord channel wants to come
on and talk about series 2 of stargate
um but we're going to be doing that and
then guys
get in the comments later tell us what
sort of videos or things you want me and
stormy to talk about in the future on a
sunday night live with you and we will
because that's how this [ __ ] works you
tell us how much it works
if you tell us
well actually how it works is you give
us suggestions i ignore the ones i don't
want to talk about and i pick the ones
that i do want to talk about that's how
it actually works then he forces me to
gap about it
yeah exactly but
throw
it out there and you never know some of
it might stick
guys and stormy thank you so much very
very welcome see you guys thank you oh
wait a second i gotta do the outro a bit
always
[Music]